élégant technique vif et rapide les
qualificatifs se bousculent quand les
spécialistes parlent de rappel varun ses
points forts ses anticipations
c'est un joueur qui est qui et élégant
un défenseur de très grande qualité
le jeune raphaël né à lille cinq ans
avant la première victoire de la france
en coupe du monde ne respirait pas le
foot à ses débuts le dernier de la
fratrie des varannes comment son
parcours sportif par le rugby l'histoire
raconte que c'est le racing club de lens
qui détectera une précocité rare chez un
enfant âgé seulement de neuf ans son
ascension dans le milieu très fermé du
foot est rare à 16,1 alors qu'il vient
tout juste d'être sacré vice champion de
france des moins de 17 ans il est
propulsé en 2009 chez les moines 19
l'année suivante intégré dans le groupe
professionnel
le martiniquais devient la révélation de
la saison 2010 2011
convoité par les plus grands clubs
européens ont fait le choix sur les
conseils de zidane du real madrid
le jeu propre et incisif du madrilène a
toujours impressionné les observateurs
ça fait des années qu'ils enchaînent
keane ancien qu'il enchaîne des matches
mardon à au real madrid dont l'une des
plus grandes équipes au monde c'est pas
sa joie requis
ouais qui a réfléchi pour console tu as
le plus jeune joueur j'avais écouté par
le patron de madrid n'a jamais été
impressionné par l'ébullition médiatique
autour de sa personne la nuit de son
recrutement au real il passe
tranquillement son bac
sur le terrain après une première
expérience en ligue des champions 2011 à
bernabéu
bahreïn est appelée l'année suivante
pour la première fois en équipe de
france
titulaire au détriment de pépé au real
dès 2016 il devient l'élément de base de
la défense des blés incontournable en
club et en équipe nationale d'appel
varane fait aujourd'hui figure de patron
de force tranquille
à seulement 24 ans auréolé de quatre
ligue des champions le personnage force
le respect de ses coéquipiers et un peu
écoeurant et la 24 ans as fait quatre
ans qu'il est en équipe de france c'est
notre coupe d'europe je tout le mal que
je souhaite c'est mangane est encore
plein d'autres comme la majorité des
footballeur raphaël varane puise son
équilibre auprès de ses proches sa
compagne camille et sa fille ruben mais
l'international français ne manque
jamais d'avoir une pensée pour le pays
qui a vu naître son père
[Musique]
à la vue de l'engouement qu'avait
suscitées ici la victoire des bleus
contre l'argentine
raphaël varane a par notre biais voulu
faire passer ce message
un petit coucou à toute la martinique on
continue d'envahir les bleus